لا اعلم ما اذا وصلت تل ابيب الى نقطه
تحول لكنه وضع صعب جدا اذ اشعر بالقلق على
اسرائيل واملوا ان يتخلى نتنياهو عن مشروع
التعديلات القضائيه
اخبار العالم باجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم ازمه تعديلات القضائيه في
اسرائيل تتواصل ولا حلول في الافق حيث قال
من ان ياهو ان اسرائيل ترفض الضغوط حتى من
اقرب الاصدقاء قبل يتراجع ويوعظ الوزراءه
بعدم التعقيب على تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي
التي قال فيها انه لا يعتزم دعوه نتنياهو
لزياره واشنطن وسط مسائل من احزاب
الائتلاف الحكومي والمعارضه للوصول الى
توافق بشان التعديلات
مع استمرار القتال في ضخمه مؤسس المعركه
من اجل المدينه دمرت الجيش الاوكراني
والحقت ضررا بالغا بقواته بينما قالت
موسكو انه من المستحيل تحقيق اهداف
عملياته العسكريه بالسياسه والدبلوماسيه
وفي المقابل اعرب
عن قلقه من تداعياتي اي تغير للحكم في
واشنطن على الحرب
حمزه يوسف يؤدي اليمين الدستوريه رئيس
الوزراء اسكتلندا بعد تصويت البرلمان على
تعيينه وفوزه بزعامه الحزب الوطني الحاكم
ليصبح اول رئيس حكومه مسلم يقود حكومه
مفوضه في المملكه المتحده وقد لقت صوره
نشرها حمزه وهو يام عائلته بالصلاه لاول
مره في مقر الحكومه بعد الافطار لقد
تفاعلا واسعا على المنصات
الفيفا يعلن تجريد اندونيسيا من حق
استضافه بطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم تحت
20 عاما المقرر في 2023 اثر رفض حاكم
جزيره بالي استضافه المنتخب الاسرائيلي
بينما اشار الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم انه
سيتم تحديد طبيعه العقوبات المحتمله ضد
الاتحاد الاندونيسي في مرحله لاحقا الى
اللقاء